I'm Lydia and I'm a flight biologist the
fittest bird Ducks they do they [ __ ]
dead ducks
yeah they rape the gang rape and they
also have like really spiny penises as
well it's like a spiral it's like a
drill scientist you went to go study
penguins in the Victorian times and he
realized that they did the whole
necrophilia thing killing each other and
gay sex and he couldn't publish any of
it because he said it was too scandalous
at the time I'm more involved with
flight say how birds fly exactly which
is slightly different flight evolves
four times separately okay
can you name them so good yeah fish fish
it's not flight but yeah Wilbur and
Orville yes and the last one which is
really easy and albatross is a bird oh
no fly buzzing you know everything Chris
I challenge you to rap about people who
keep their confetti from their wedding
day they found that there's a pesticide
which turns Birds gay and finally I want
you to wrap up our shoelaces shoelaces
keeping confetti from the wedding and
the pesticide that turns Birds gay yeah
there we go
I got a question I'd be like what's up
y'all why you're hard and confetti from
your nuptials yeah you just should not
care about the tiny paper all the metal
thrown in the air you don't need it you
keep it
what for yeah I know you keep the cake
in your freezer drawer you just need one
slice or maybe two twice but banks are
confetti happily like not nicely what do
you need it for maybe to watch for the
dashing you throw it in the air when
it's your friends trashing a very nice
reference if you didn't go to Oxford or
Cambridge but hey whole like the Seven
Dwarfs yeah I'm on to the second course
I wanna make sure look my shoes are
short of my feet I'll be like oh no I
don't like hooks and eyes cannot stand
velcro so I do something I turn about
face I be like I want to get a wax
shoelace and put it right in here never
forget I put it through the eyelet using
the aglet okay
I say you're fat yeah I hope you don't
mind yeah the aglet is the correct term
not the flugel Barnes or some people
think it is but their brain just failed
it's a kind of urban legend from the
film cocktail yo
third thing yeah I never understand a be
spread and stuff all over England trying
to make the crops grow and make them go
higher but birds like they bros they've
been like I'm no liar I see you down
there I'm so impressed I'm like hey
great tits
I like your breasts and if you like whoa
collect yourself y'all previously this
bird was heterosexual but now it just
James yo it's enough in all the colonies
having gay sex as the puffins they just
poppin losing breath when they bone in
the nest they be like my wife yo she not
impressed she got a family to raise not
with the gay bird it is found unless
you're in certain places in the States
they don't like that yo they appalled
they'd be like no it should be a man and
female eggs child but you got it you get
inside I don't wanna be snide about the
pesticide we need the food it provides
and not be like what hey it doesn't
matter if it turns any Birds game beat
how many forces by all ever sound in my
head they were great great today